depuis la décision de sa fermeture en
avril 2015 la piscine de maurepas pose
bien des problèmes à la municipalité le
projet de reconstruction d'un centre
aquatique intercommunal entre maurepas
elancourt à plusieurs points de conflit
le collectif piscine pour tous s'est
constitué en mai dernier
ses membres étaient présents mardi soir
pour manifester avant le conseil
municipal et tentaient de s'y exprimer
la concertation qui a été menée pendant
l'été est largement insuffisante la
concertation menée par les maires est
largement insuffisante elle est
lacunaire
elle est imprécise et elle laisse en
suspens de très nombreuses questions
pour répondre aux missions de service
public des arguments incompris par le
maire de la ville qui a consulté les
habitants il ya quelques mois et obtenu
plus de 3000 réponse est fait avec mon
collègue des locaux et de coignières à
l'époque une grande concertation sur
plus de quatre mois entre 20 et
septembre grand public avec un
questionnaire sur internet papier dans
les trois villes on a fait des groupes
de travail avec l'ensemble des
associations
on a fait des groupes de travail avec
les collèges les représentants des
collèges et des lycées
on a recueilli tous ses besoins
principal sujet d'inquiétude pour le
collectif partagé avec l'opposition la
délégation de service à une entreprise
privée
le maire de maurepas tient à rappeler
qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une privatisation
on vous déléguez affaires publiques dans
le privé il y a toujours un contrôle de
la puissance publique qui ait lieu tous
les ans au travers d'un rapport du
délégué ter qui est votée en conseil
municipal et ensuite vous avez les
agents de la collectivité qui suivent de
près l'exécution du contrat fait une
obligation dans le cadre des marchés
publics le recours à la gestion déléguée
signé l'appel d'offres sera lancé le 17
décembre pour un lancement des travaux
fin 2019
le collectif se dit pourtant déterminé à
poursuivre ses actions et appelle les
citoyens à les rejoindre